he's a doc Emmerich the elite
play-by-play announcer for NBC's NHL
coverage he'll be on the call game to
Blues Bruins tomorrow night 8:00 Eastern
on NBC he's won the Sports Emmy I
believe six times and doc joins us now
on the program good morning doc how are
you I don't know I think it would be an
interesting contest doc you know the
answer to that question no he could not
the answer is he could not and half the
NBA could not I would when are you
coming into the man cave if I had you
shoot 25 free throws da camera crew
throws are you making I would send a
surrogate to take them for me and his
name would be Brian Boucher because we
had that contest in Washington where the
practice floor for the Wizards is right
next to the rent at the morning skate
and without a warm-up eddie old tech and
I and Brian Boucher all took three foul
shots Eddie and I were over three and
Brian did not even hit the rim on three
it's it the net all three times without
a warm-up over the summer and I don't
know how long it been and we did get a
perfect well you're from Indiana you got
to be able to shoot doc I shoot like
Ollie in the poster on the wall at our
high school gym and without in Indiana
on how to shoot foul shots and it showed
definitively that's how you did it but
it was the 1950s and so that was how it
was
by the way down thanks for relating that
story on Bill Buckner because I've never
heard that before
and last night we were preparing to say
something about Bill eventually Mike
Tirico didn't our telecast as we had
earlier in the playoffs in Boston what
John Havlicek passed and when doing the
results and library work never King
philosphers likely related but you had
mentioned that the nervous automatically
went through this last decade he was in
the majors not only did he ever strike
out more than 40 times he never
walk more than 40 times when he went up
there he was a hitter I don't know if he
ever struck out three times in a game is
an entire career over 2500 games I don't
think he struck out three times in a
game can you imagine that that's day in
and day out playing things really close
brawling and all the tricks but the guys
on the mound have and you still you're
still not getting whipped I had well it
was marvelous and I just wanted you to
know that dollars than the in the much
way I've never heard those stories
before yeah just to be in the locker
room to relate and you've been around
this though doc that we focus on the
winners but it's how the losers handle
losing that always fascinates me and you
know hockey those guys you know they
battle they they you know they beat each
other up and then they shake hands with
hunt or nod but you know there there's
admiration in battle when I watch hockey
and you know you have guys who have had
some you know great moments but you've
also had some guys who have had you know
they've been the goat they in not in the
good way
know and Steve Smith wound up putting
the puck in in his own net off his
goaltender and it is forever remembered
in if Anton despite the fact they want
all those championships it's one of
those things that he was remembered for
but yet has had a glowing career sense
not only as a player but also as a
member of a coaching staff those things
I guess just never never leave the
consciousness but you try never to let
them ruin your life and the sad thing is
that sports fans tend to be sharks yes
and they can they can cause your family
to suffer that was I was always sad to
know that he had to move out of New
England all the way out to Idaho for
that it was great story that you told
not only about him in Mitch Williams and
I just wanted to mention thank you doing
research yesterday and and it never
Trump's a personal story like you
related and I'm just glad you did
because those are things that you you
continue to try to do to make sure that
Bill Buckner does not remember for just
one thing
he's doc Emmerich he called last night's
game one he's got game two tomorrow
night the
and Bruns if I would have told you in
October the blues and Bruins would be
playing for the cup you would have said
no it would be Tampa Bay on somebody but
no I wouldn't expected that it would
have been that it would have been in the
Bruins I would have said oh it's
probably going to be an open tournament
and 16 and because it's always that way
but by November or early December I
would have said it's going to be time to
play the favorite to get to the final
which they were all the way through but
I don't think anyone would have given
st. Louis much of a chance especially by
the time we got to January and they were
dead last they moved from 31st to 12:00
from the first of January right up to
noon to early April it was a magnificent
story and attributed to not only some
splendid goaltending but the unification
of the team under under a coach named
Craig Berube whose term of play in the
NHL was courageous and fisted
one one source claims that in the
history of the NHL he had more fighting
majors than any other player including
Tiger Williams that's the kind of life
he led as a player and he became this
very cerebral Coates that knows how to
motivate players and rallied a team and
turned him into the second best team in
the playoffs as of today because they're
trailing in the final series on tonight
it feels like the tough guys are
disguised a little bit more doc that
you're not just out there for one thing
that there's a it's there's more nuance
to being a tough guy in the NHL is that
is that fair to say oh yes you know
fighting is gone now especially in the
playoffs when I first started doing NHL
games in the playoffs in 1980 it would
be nothing to have 85 playoff games and
85 total fights in the playoffs this
year we've had 81 games and three fights
and this will be the record if it stays
at that I mean the low number that we've
had in recent years the lowest has been
seven so just give you an idea of that
so now the guys that are the courage
players are the ones that that go
flailing into the corners and and hit
continuously and we have two teams full
of guys that do just that which is why
this is such an engrossing entertaining
series we have big body guys that have
been on teams that have gotten to the
final so maybe there'll be a trend now
to having larger players that can
withstand the punishment that you need
to get through four rounds and win a
championship there are smaller teams or
teams that have smaller players that
have gone by the wayside in the first
round or second round this year and here
are two of the bigger stronger more
aggressive teams that have gotten to the
final so in terms of what it takes to do
now the the fighters are in the sport
are pretty much gone but the guys that
are aggressive and really assert
themselves they're very much there and
they're very important to their teams
how much hockey did you play growing up
none I grew up in rural Indiana and
there were two indoor arenas in the
state of Indiana one was the Coliseum in
Fort Wayne where a team called the
Comets and a team called the Pistons in
the NBA played and there was the
Indianapolis fairgrounds Coliseum that
was it for the state of Indiana when I
grew up that was my excuse and the other
was I wasn't very athletic man I learned
to shoot under hand towel shots in a
little town in Indiana and there was not
a whole lot else but when I saw my first
game in Fort Wayne I became fascinated
with the sport and obsessed with it that
was a long time ago are you the most
famous person from your hometown no
Chester Troyer created a bunch of hybrid
seeds and needed Tesla troyler seeds to
raise corn I think he would have
probably been far more productive than I
was but he also grew up in the fountain
Indiana are you the most decorated guy
though with hockey you know you've been
around all these players man Gretzky had
a pretty good career but you're more
decorated than Gretzky aren't you with
all your awards I don't know no
Wayne records and I don't know 40 or 50
records no by no means and Wayne can go
anywhere he wants I still need a prize
yeah and and I have a fast that I'm
gonna be wearing around my neck to go to
practice with a big smile on my face
because every day incas fun for me Pauly
would you check on Chester Troyer if he
ever called a Stanley Cup final Chester
e the corn King Troyer never called a
Stanley Cup final okay never not even
one not one not one he did a lot of work
in the corn industry no NHL final no
Stanley Cup on came only streak for
Boston - Corrales was now set up 213
shots and that compares favorably
compared to McLovin artists eaten the
last time I was there
Wow and I saw first hand Seaton beaten
McLovin on the floor of the man cave Wow
yes yes yes yes during a commercial
break now I realized McLovin didn't have
the best equipment in goal to stop him
with well McLovin is a rule type more
Roy - yeah you're right he is he is it's
fabulous though you guys are so much fun
Thank You doc and tell everybody we set
a low and we'll be watching tonight
outstanding that's doc Hamrick lead
play-by-play announcer for NBC's NHL
coverage for more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]